The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
SEBASTIAN DETERDING: It's a
best selling techno thriller
turned into a movie, which
is about a demo, a semi
autonomous program
gaining full autonomy
and using levelling systems
from an MMORPG to basically turn
humans into a second speaker
society controlled by computers
instead of the other way around.
And connected to that
theory is definitely led
by the rise of the term or
the concept gamification,
somewhere around 2010 or 2011,
if you follow Google search
interests.
The idea that you could use
elements from games or game
design as a kind of monosodium
glutamate or crunchy
flakes to edit some other stuff
to make some other stuff more
palatable.
And if there is one
thing true to this term
is that it has the heated
debate from the get go.
On the one hand, you have
people like the ones who read,
Gabe Zicherman, he says's
it's the best tools
humanity has ever invented
to create and sustain
engagement in people game.
On the other hand, you have
people like Ian Bogus for those
choice words
[LAUGHTER] [INAUDIBLE],
which of course is
a technical term,
it's a technical term in
philosophy by Harry G.
Frankfurt, describing people
who just don't care whether what
they say is true or untrue.
So when me and my colleague
Stephen [INAUDIBLE] we're
looking at the debate
around 2011-2012,
we couldn't help noticing
a couple of things.
First thing we noticed
is-- as I said,
this is a really heated debate.
This is so heated
that this is not just
the difference of
opinion, there must
be something deeper
underlying here
than just difference of opinion.
And second, while evangelizers
were evangelizing,
and critiques were
chastising, very few people
asked, well, what does the
gamification even mean?
What are the larger
consequences, the larger
ramifications of this for us as
individuals living in a society
where these kind of systems
become more prevelant,
or for us as a society?
That's kind of the origin story
of how this book came about.
In this book, most
of what I'm talking
about in the first chaper,
the history chapter,
is basically what I'm
talking about here so.
While we were digging a
bit deeper in this thing,
saying why this
heated discourse?
Why are people so angry?
We found that gamification--
the gamification discourse--
is very much in the same
state that the discourse
around playing was in
the late 1990s, when
the late Bryan Smith [INAUDIBLE]
game [INAUDIBLE] play.
Show of hands, anybody
know the ambiguitive play?
OK.
Show of hands who's involved
in some form of game studies
or game research program?
Yeah, that mapping
sort of makes sense,
if you're into game research,
you should at a certain point
come across this book.
What Sutton Smith and this book
basically makes the argument
and then shows is that he says
the reason why there hasn't
been a lot of agreement
about what players
and what we should
do with the play is
that the different disciplines
of different rhetorics,
different ways of framing
the play that are grounded
in different deeper cultural
rhetorics about what plays
should be and how
plays should function.
As it says, rhetorics
of plays [INAUDIBLE]
placed within broader
value systems.
The popular rhetorics in the
listed settings, the ambiguity
is that there would be
seven different rhetorics,
and nobody can
ever agree on one.
There are these different, large
scale cultural ways of thought
in which we, more or
less, all participate.
And that's the reason
why that debate never
really comes really close.
And in the same
way, when we look
at the gamification
[INAUDIBLE] and say yeah,
that really captures pretty
well the happening here.
There is a disagreement
here about what
the proper plays
of plain society
should be to begin with
about should playing games be
used to begin before
anything else or not?
And if so, how
should they be used?
By whom should they be used, and
for what should they be used?
Because the thing
that we observe,
the series games of
gaminification with playful
designs-- all these
different terms,
it's basically a kind
of dual cultural moment.
On the one hand, games in play
leave the traditional spaces
that they've been confined
in within our modern Western
nation states and cultures.
This was the leisure time
of things you did together
with your friends
in the evening,
and there were certain
kinds of games.
And suddenly, there were
also games for learning.
Suddenly, there was
games for politics.
And suddenly, everybody plays.
And then part of that, what
you get as a response to that
is that just games
become more and more
pervasive in everyday life,
which we call dilutification
of culture.
You see that other
social actors become
interested in using
games and in impressing
norms, and regulations,
and values onto games.
So suddenly, you have a big
debate where people say well,
games should be gender
aware, and games
should be more
diverse, because look
at what turbo misogynistic
space this is.
And then you have the
existing male game cultures
revolting against that,
as this result that game
play becomes more pervasive.
Suddenly, you have a
cultural discourse.
Leave out for all the terrible,
terrible online harassment
of gamer [INAUDIBLE].
But underneath that is this
underlying cultural discourse,
who should be allowed
to play games?
Who should games be for?
Who should be able to
make these decisions?
So if Ian Bogost says
something-- gamification
is marketing bullshit
as a means to capture
the wild, coveted beast
that is video games
and to domesticate it.
Games are a mysterious,
magical, powerful medium.
He basically says there's
this nature of games.
This is how games are.
They're beasts.
They're this thing.
And then suddenly, they try
to tame and domesticate.
What he's basically
saying is games
belong to us, the game
designers, and the gamers,
and the game academics.
But you marketers, please stay
out of our playing fields.
This is not you should lose
games, which obviously forgets
that games have been used
for all kinds of purposes
for the longest
period in history.
The art game has
[INAUDIBLE] and fluxes
where Ian Bogost, with
this game [INAUDIBLE]
definitely also
belongs to, or be it
war gaming, which
basically goes back
to Sun Tzu and The Art
of War, because Sun
Tzu, The Art of War, partially
was based on the culture where
samurai were taught strategy
and cunning with good things
of [INAUDIBLE] as a board game.
So the idea that you could
use games for other things
than entertainment is
culturally very old.
But still, we have suddenly
this new cultural debate
about how should we
use games in society?
What should their place be?
And even deeper underlying
that, what kind of society
do we want to live in to begin
with, and how do we get there?
And as we were noticing these
kind of clashes of rhetorics,
we found two
theoreticians very useful
in mapping the total debate.
The first one is this very
unlikely, with Victor Turner,
of the [INAUDIBLE] to theater.
And he's an anthropologist,
very famous for his early work
about ritual as a
social phenomenon
for all of those pictures.
And he noticed that in
pre-modern cultures that
was played obviously
that was also played,
the play was usually very well
coached and functionalized
in these cultures,
namely in passage rights.
Passage rights, he says,
were these liminal spaces,
boundary spaces where
people would temporarily
leave their existing
space in society,
and play around, and
act excessively to then
be reintegrated into
society into their new role,
usually in their passage
between being a child,
and then being the
responsible adult.
You still have that kind of
thing in the Amish [INAUDIBLE]
in certain Amish
communities where
once you're considered
to be at the age
where you can become
an adult, basically,
you get to leave the community,
do all the things you were
never allowed to do in an
Amish community-- jump around
is the literal
translation, [GERMAN];
it's from the Germans-- and then
make the decision whether you
want to return.
So you get to play around
very literally, as [INAUDIBLE]
said, in these places.
But this is completely
functionalized as a ritual
to reproduce society.
And what we noticed is in modern
societies, singular societies,
these liminal
spaces disappeared.
We don't have a lot
of them, because we're
not a strongly religious
society anymore.
But there were
societal spaces that
retain forms and
shapes of that, only
they're used and functionalized
in different ways.
And to notify this, to
indicate this distinction,
he makes a distinction
between liminal and liminoid.
He says where it's liminal
spaces, like passage rights,
like the pre-modern, religious,
and collective things that
are obligatory.
We have to do them, their
play is instrumentalized.
It's a means towards the end
of getting you into society.
It reproduces the
existing social order
and improves the means.
It's a means towards producing
society, whereas limioid spaces
play becomes something that's
not instrumental, but also
telling, done for its sake.
Play becomes something where
you can change the order, even
if temporarily.
You can upset the
social order, and play
becomes a space where you
can question the end society
pursuits.
Should we get through this,
instead of just reproducing it?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Well, what did you
say about the [INAUDIBLE]?
What is that?
SEBASTIAN DETERDING:
Autotelic is from the Greek.
Auto, self, and telos is goal.
And autotelic means
something is its own goal.
I do it for its own sake.
AUDIENCE: OK.
SEBASTIAN DETERDING:
I eat because I
enjoy eating, not because
something else, as an example.
So he notices that we
have not these ritual
spaces like passage
rights so much anymore,
but we have these
liminoid spaces.
These are spaces like art.
He uses bases like
science, where you
get to toy around with ideas.
These are spaces like theater.
These are spaces like play.
These are time play.
All these spaces retain
these ritual functions,
but they're somehow
used differently.
Give you a very
practical example.
Art-- religious art
in pre-modern times
was a liminal space that
just presented and reproduced
the religious order
as it should be.
I'm just showing you how it
should be, [INAUDIBLE], and so
on, whereas modern liminoid
art is allowed to toy
around with this and use the
imagery literally, play around
with the imagery of
previous pre-modern art,
remix it with Coca-Cola presents
the crucification of Christ
to make critical,
soulful commentary,
to speak about is this the
kind of commercialized society
in which we live and should be
living in that kind of society.
And we found this distinction
between lininal and liminoid
helped us very well to tease
out the different political
positions people had
towards communification.
The second poll that we
found was very useful
is from another book that most
of the game studies people
know, that is [INAUDIBLE],
a French philosopher
in the 1950s, Men Playing
Games, [FRENCH], or [FRENCH]?
[FRENCH]?
AUDIENCE: [FRENCH].
SEBASTIAN DETERDING: Yeah,
where he said that basically,
all kinds of play and
game forms, that we
have a culture, a loosely
folding on a spectrum of two
poles.
One pole he declares with
the Latin ludus for basically
a rule based game that's very
orderly, where you strive
in order to reach goals;
every typical board
game, or social game,
or video game that you
can think of on the one hand.
And on the other hand, you have
this free form improvisational,
explorational, tumultuous play.
Think about children playing
pretend play, or Lego.
So all games and play forms have
basically these two ideal poles
in them, and things fall
somewhere on these poles.
And we notice that if we
take these two dimensions
and look at all the
different rhetorics--
and we could talk about
the rhetorics later.
But if we take all the
different rhetorics
there are, then
they pretty neatly
form this clear clustering.
They fall into two
clusters of opinions
which are these underlying
rhetorical disagreements
about what games and plays
should be in society.
On the one hand, you
have people who very much
like games-- structures.
There's more structures, more
rules, more feedback systems
that are very liminal,
but not liminal
in the traditional,
pre-modern way reproducing
religious order, but
liminal in a modern way,
reproducing the existing
social order of society.
Basically, their position's the
current social order is good.
It's perfect.
Society should be as it is, but
it has some flaws in execution,
and we should use
gains as technologies
that governments and
organizations can
use to perfect the execution.
It's not that the way
organizations or businesses
organized as broken.
It's just that people
aren't motivated enough,
so games are a great tool
to motivate them more.
I thought maybe we should fix
the organizations themselves,
whereas the opposite poll, most
people who say gamification's
bad are the ones
who more or less see
the current social order as bad.
They are typically
progressive and critical
in general in their
political views.
But say play-- the
practice of play,
like the [INAUDIBLE] thing is
a great practice for people
to resist the existing
order and discover together
what kind of world
we want to begin with
and to give you just some ideas
of these different rhetorics
that we find.
So some of the rhetorics
are, for instance, things
like well being.
That's people like
Jane McGonigal,
people like Miguel [INAUDIBLE],
people like myself that
speak about self determination
theory, [INAUDIBLE],
the good life.
And we all say well,
what's the good life
that we all aspire to?
And obviously, in light of
that, our current society's
pretty broken.
But here's the thing about play.
Play is a realized
form of the good life,
so we all strive to get there,
or things like performance.
So these are people
who do pervasive games
or who do LARPs, like
action role playing games;
all these much, much more free
form play form to say, well,
these are great
activities for people
to get together and
experience that they
can form a community, even if
a temporal community together.
And on the other hand, you have
rhetorics like reinforcement,
so people like
[INAUDIBLE] and others
who raw on behaviorist modes
of thinking or behaviorist
modes of thinking about
games and say games
are basically these
incentives doling machines.
And so therefore,
they're a great way
of reproducing or incentivizing
certain behaviors.
Or a bit more complex, nudging.
A lot of people say games
are basically nudges.
Just a show of hands, who
knows the term nudging
as a technical term?
OK.
So who knows behavioral
economics as a term?
So neoclassical
economics basically
says people are rational actors.
Give me the right information.
Give me the right
incentives, and I
will do what you want me to do.
If I know this is helpful for
me, and I care about my health,
I'm definitely going
to act healthy.
Only then, psychology showed
us that is not the case.
You can give people
as much information,
and they might care as much as
they want about their health,
but they still don't behave
healthily necessarily
which led a lot of
economists saying to us well,
why then do people
behave unhealthily?
And they started to run
empirical experiments
where they say, this is how
economic theory predicts
how people will
behave, and here's
how they actually behave.
So there is a gap
there between the two,
but this gap is predictable.
It's a repeating.
It's a reoccurring pattern.
One of these reoccurring
patterns, for instance,
is temporal discounting, which
is just a fancy technical term
for I care for the thing
right in front of me
much more than for a
thing way in the future.
If they did actual economic
disbursement to people saying,
do you want $1 now or
$100 a month from now?
A pure rational actor
would always take the $100,
let's say.
Because again, in no way,
shape, or form will inflation,
by that point, have
invalidated the $100 that much.
But they found the majority
of people took the $1 now.
And so they enlisted
all these kind
of cognitive biases
and heuristics,
these weird ways
in which we deviate
from actual rational behavior.
And then they said look at
games, at least that rhetoric.
They said look at games.
They're basically
machines for exploiting
these kind of reliable
flaws in our thinking.
And so therefore,
games are great for us
to learn how to exploit
them to get people
to do other stuff, as well.
So so much for that.
I'd like to finish, as I said,
with teasing out scenarios,
so what are the visions
underlying here then?
Then we'll get into debating.
Namely, what are the positive or
negative visions that come out
of these different rhetorics?
Starting with the positive one,
on both sides that we face,
you can slice and
dice them as you want.
I slice and dice them in three
positive scenarios, and lots
of issues with them that
we can no longer debate.
The positive vision, the
best possible world version
of engagement-- the first
one is engagement, which
is a terrible, over-used term.
But it's basically the idea that
we can harness all the three
cycles, all the free
energy, all the cognitive
surplus', [INAUDIBLE].
Thanks to the fact that
people are now online, and no
necessarily always
watching television,
we can use all the hours
they poured into Wikipedia
for really productive purposes.
And then people
like Jane McGonigal
said well, that's great.
If we could use games,
you can learn from games.
And she put in this paper,
because it's basically
the white paper that
underlies, "Reality is Broken,"
which she wrote back at the
institute for the future.
We can use games as engines
for a massively [INAUDIBLE]
collaboration and participation
to organize and incite people
towards productive
things like solving
complex scientific
issues, and science games,
or stuff like that, or use
games for civic participation,
or the aspect of games,
like DIY democracy,
where you would get points
for being an active citizen.
The one issue-- lots of
issues, but one issue
I have with that is even if
that would insight engagement
of people-- for instance,
use this to report pot holes
in your street, it would
always structure participation
of people in a certain manner.
So if we see this as
a vision of society,
we have to be aware that every
structure for participation
creates structures of
who gets to participate,
who's included in the executing.
You can also say who
has technological access
to these kinds of tools?
Who runs around the whole
time with a smartphone?
Who even cares about this?
Who has the technological
literacy to use these tools?
That is with all the
citizen participation
tools, who actually uses
this to report pot holes?
And again, you find that
this is very much stratified
by socio-economic status.
The second positive
vision is community.
That's what I talked about as
performance is the idea that we
can use games and play
to bring people together
and to experience hey,
we like each other.
We're pretty much alike.
We want the same
things, and we think
that this thing in our society
is built, and so let's together
get together and fix it.
So it's a way of
bringing together people
into new forms of community.
This goes back to
early movements,
like the new games
movement back in the Bay
Area in the 1970s which
underlies a lot of the still
Utopian thinking in Silicon
Valley where they basically
said with the Vietnam
War going, can't we
create non-competitive games
that get people together
in order to understand
that that is also
a form of co-existing instead
of constantly combating
each other?
And as Stewart Brand
back then said,
you can't change a game by
winning it, or losing it,
or refereeing it,
or spectating it,
because then you're still
playing by the rules.
You still have to create
a new game together
to leave the old
society and to move on.
And contemporary
examples of that
are things like you're
guerrilla gardening,
and there are games
around guerrilla gardening
as a community.
Or my favorite example is
Massively Multiplayer Soba
by tilt factor.
The treasure hunt
through New York,
through one of New York's
most diverse neighborhoods.
And the idea is the
difference teams
get sheets with
ingredients that they
have to bring to
the final cookout,
where people cook together,
only the ingredients are
written in different languages;
Hebrew, Hindi, whatever.
So you have to go through
this neighborhood,
find people to translate
the ingredients to you,
and then tell you
where you actually find
all these local ingredients.
That way, naturally
getting into conversations
with people in that neighborhood
you would otherwise never
have talked to.
And then the game
gives you extra points
for bringing stories about
food from that culture
or bringing actual people
from the neighborhood
to the final cookout.
One issue again--
lots of issues,
but one issue with
that is that I'm always
wondering to what extent--
these are basically
again, things hipsters can do
to make themselves feel well
versus to what extent are
these things that actually cite
large scale social action or
commodify your [INAUDIBLE],
you'll find.
The third positive vision
is hacking; hacking systems.
The underlying idea there,
and a lot of the references
will say well, if there's
one thing about games that's
great it's their systems.
Or one thing game's
good at is systems,
and one thing that
you can do with games
is you learn systems thinking.
Anybody know September 12?
One of the early news
games, persuasive games.
The idea came out right
after September 11th,
shortly thereafter
by Gonzalo Frasca.
You basically see
this little landscape
in some long,
disparate Arab country.
You see some people
running around
in quote, unquote,
"terrorist" uniforms,
and then you just have
this targeting circle.
And then you can
choose whether you want
to fire bombs with them or not.
When you fire bombs,
inevitably you
will create collateral
damage in terms
of people and other things.
And inevitably,
people standing around
that will mourn for the
dead, and then some of them
will likewise transform
into terrorists.
So it's the systemic model
of violence beget violence.
By attacking, you will only
create more resistance,
basically.
You may disagree
with the argument,
but it's a basic
way of showing you
how games can model a
system and show a system
and can [INAUDIBLE] systems.
So the argument of
hacking, as well;
games are great for
systems thinking
or learnings to this
kind of systems thinking.
And by making games
about the broken systems
we live in, like in those
airport and security,
about constantly changing
new rules; what is allowed,
what is not allowed.
You notice how broken that
kind of TSA system is,
and by learning to
build systems ourselves
through game design and all
kinds of tools that open up
game design for other
people, we might actually
educate a generation
of people who can then
use that game design
and knowledge in order
to redesign the broken social
systems in which we live.
The issue with
that is obviously,
anybody has yet to show me
that there is data for that,
that that actually happens.
OK.
Final three, dystopia.
The first one is
obviously the one
that you most likely will come
across the most [INAUDIBLE]
when people were talking
about gamification.
That is this is a
perfect control society.
And my favorite one, has anybody
seen the talk by Jesse Schell?
The Gamepocalypse.
That's one of the other
initial pieces of media
that the whole
gamification thing started.
It's a talk he gave in 2010
at a game design conference,
and he described the
future world in which game
designers would rule.
And on, and on, and on it goes.
It's a five minute riff within
the talk where he just runs
with the idea and says, what
if all kinds of organizations
and governments
would basically start
to use point of
incentives systems
to get people to do
everything they want to do.
And people say, this is silly.
This is ridiculous.
This is also scary.
The only thing is it's
also becoming a reality.
Shortly after the talk, there
was this sort of green goose
which actually did sensor kids.
So you can use ubiquitous
computing everywhere,
especially to brush your teeth.
Some people are obsessed
with brushing their teeth
and getting points for it-- to
measure everything, and then
set up your own reward
system for that,
and you have these
default senses that you
can use for everything else.
And if you say well, that's
nice if it's for people.
That's not what
organizations do-- well,
this year's one part
of the health program
that I was introduced to at
Northeastern, which I find very
cute, which is Virgin Pulse.
Basically, it's one of these
health trackers, step trackers.
And if I use the step tracker
for my university, hey.
I actually get
points, and the points
are translated into
reduced insurance premiums.
Now you might say well-- a lot
of my colleagues said well,
this is great.
You're getting money, so
why shouldn't I do it?
I said well, I don't
know if I actually
want either my employer
or my health insurance
to know how healthy or unhealthy
my behavior [INAUDIBLE] myself.
And then the next time
I switch an insurance,
the insurance looks at
the data and says-- hm.
We should raise your premium.
The larger issue behind
that is basically
that most of these
systems are at face value
are sold as more
fun or rewards or
empowerment to the individual.
Like Rescue Time
is this application
that you can let running.
And then it tells
you, just by keeping
in the back end, what
kind of applications
were running all through
the day and what kind
of browser windows
you had open in order
to discover what you're time
syncs are in order to be more
productive as an individual.
Yay.
Only then there's
this nice button,
Looking for Rescue Time for
Entire Team or Organization,
click here.
And then you see the
management feature
which allows the manager,
who installs this
all across the team to see
exactly what everybody's
actually doing on their
computer the whole day.
And obviously, this
issue is true everywhere
we use gamified
applications are installed,
which according to the
vision, will be everywhere.
So you can even
imagine something
like Amazon saying
hey, because we
want people to read
more books, we're
going to deal out
virtual rewards
and incentives for
people to read more,
because then we make more
money only while I do so.
And then I read all the
volumes of Das Capital,
somebody else might
also be interested
in that kind of data, that
I'm actually currently
interested in Marxism.
The third issue there is that
face value of fun and self
realization at companies.
And all Silicon Valley
companies have to have sleds.
This here is at YouTube.
Obviously, a YouTube red.
I recently did a bit of
research around playful offices.
They really have all sleds
somehow, for some reason.
We can talk about that.
But that, in the back end, is
really covert exploitation.
We make it so fun and so
comfy here in this place
that you never want to leave
the workplace, at which point
then, you get suicides
and exhaustion in places
like the Las Vegas downtown
project run by Zappos there,
or as [INAUDIBLE] nicely
put it, gamification
is a mechanism of
decoupling alienation.
I feel like I'm not
realizing myself.
I feel I'm not doing
what I'm passionate
about from exploitation.
With gamification, I may not
be alienated by my working,
or this is fun.
This is great, but
I'm still exploited.
The majority of the revenue
still stays with your employer.
And the big issue
with these systems
is they're all
implemented in code.
This is all codified,
algorithmic, automated
regulation.
And the big issue with that
is you can't argue with it.
If you have an
overdraft on your bank,
you could still go
to your bank teller,
depending on which
country you are.
Here, they are typically
very neo autonomized,
but in European countries, not.
And then you can say listen,
you've known me for 10 years,
and I only need an
extension for another day,
and I'd pay the money
back, and he does so.
We know there will
always be exceptions
to the rule in reality.
The only issues with
these algorithmic system.
I can't argue with them.
I don't even know
according to which
rules they tell me yes or no
or give me certain rewards.
And I can't change
that, contrary
to other political systems.
So basically, the
control fear is
that it's on the one hand,
big brother watching you,
because it's constant
surveillance in the back,
and all your data is captured.
It comes with the
playfuls of veneers,
so it's the Aldous Huxley soma.
All this is fun and happy, and
why should we care about it?
And it's a little bit
overload, because all of this
is run by computers.
It's not even run
by people anymore.
As I said, this is going to be
the worst case scenario here.
The big issue obviously,
which I pointed out in text
here is that these
kind of control systems
destroy the very thing that
makes games fun to begin with.
They give you the freedom of
playing, voluntary choosing
to the activity.
Second, and third,
and then we're
done with negative vision.
The second negative
vision is gamification
doesn't even lead to
more control in society.
It just reproduces
existing society as it is.
It reproduces the
systems and the rhetorics
that we have in our system.
The overarching
narrative, if you
look at persuasive technology
with the quantified self,
[INAUDIBLE].
The overarching rhetoric
of all of these systems
is when we have
social issues or when
we have individual
issues like obesity,
like climate change, or
stuff like that, it's
the individual's fault.
It's the individual's fault,
because all of these systems
address individual behavior.
If only I motivated you
to run a bit better,
you'd not [INAUDIBLE].
If only I motivated you to drive
a bit more fuel efficiently
each day, we wouldn't have
global warming, basically.
That's the argument by
addressing these things
through specified applications.
So basically, the
underlying rhetoric there
is this very American one.
Anything can be accomplished
if one has the desire
and determination.
If there is a social issue, if
there is an individual issue,
it's because the individual
didn't have the willpower.
And basically, these
technical tools
just give you an augmentation
to your willpower
by motivating you if you
can't motivate yourself.
Is there anything wrong
with this rhetoric?
Well, let's see.
There are other places where
the same rhetoric was around,
like Maoist China, where
we had slogans like when
discipline's reinforced,
revolution cannot fail,
saying if the great leap forward
trying to mass industrialize
a country of several hundred
million people within the term
of five years, if that
kills millions of people,
it's not because the planet
was bonkers to begin with.
It's because the individuals
didn't put in enough effort.
In the same way, I think
gamification and lots
of persuasive technology
makes the same issue
of the background
systemic root causes.
The deeper underlying
societal issues
that are not caused
by individual behavior
necessarily or that are
not just [INAUDIBLE]
on the individual weather.
You'll interpret the [INAUDIBLE]
of environmental psychology
that recently made the
same argument where
it said, we're basically
fooling ourselves
if we believe that getting
people to recycle more
will solve any of our
environmental issues,
because municipal loves
production, just as an example.
So all the waste
that everybody of us
produces in a city
that's collected
by the municipalities,
all the waste
that we produce-- how much
is municipal waste production
from total US waste production?
What share?
Any numbers?
AUDIENCE: 10%.
SEBASTIAN DETERDING:
10%, more or less.
AUDIENCE: 5%.
SEBASTIAN DETERDING:
5%, more or less.
AUDIENCE: 2%?
SEBASTIAN DETERDING:
2%-- too low-- 3%.
So if you all recycle more,
we're reducing 10% of 3%,
whereas most of the
waste productions
happens in industrial
production.
Most of the waste production
happens in supply chains.
It doesn't happen at the
level of individual waste.
Same goes for energy savings.
Same goes for all the issues.
We're addressing the wrong
things with this kind of thing
if we're always focusing
on the individual behavior.
Third and final one
is it's not control.
It's not even reproducing
existing social order.
It's just reference.
My favorite example for
that is the PlayPump,
a system invented by a civil
engineer in South Africa
sometime in the 90s.
And in 1994, a retired
advertising executive
discovered it and said,
this is a great idea.
Let me buy the patent,
and let me make this big.
The idea of the
PlayPump is basically
lots of cities in Africa
and other developing nations
don't have enough
fresh water pumps.
So what they said
is hey, instead
of the traditional
fresh water pumps,
let's install a fresh water pump
that's actually a roundabout
and put a reservoir on top of
it that's seen here, behind.
And so water is pumped for
the local village's water
consumption by the
children playing.
Nobody has to work
for the water.
The children enjoy
using the roundabout.
They will pump the water up.
And you know how we pay
for this whole thing?
We use the reservoir as
an advertising space.
So the advertisers will pay
for the installment of this.
It's a great story.
It's a great new
story to say hey,
water is easy as child's
play, dah, dah, dah, dah, dah.
It got a great, favorable
PBS documentary,
lots of other favorable
press attention.
He got then $60
million US dollars
in aid promised from US aid.
Only then, development
aid workers
started raising their
hands and saying, sorry.
Nobody wants to advertise it
to the developing nations,
it turns out, especially
not in rural villages.
And they found out that the pump
is more difficult to install,
less efficient, more difficult
to service than existing water
pumps in other cultures.
And they found that the
average water consumption
of an average African
village is so big
that children would
have to operate
the roundabout with
their body power
for 27 continuous hours per day.
So it's impossible.
It's impossible that
children can produce
enough water [INAUDIBLE].
So therefore, it ended up
that the adults were operating
the roundabout,
only the roundabout
was built for children.
So the adults always had to
hunker down and use this one,
so they were breaking their
backs as they were doing so,
very literally.
So this thing is
a great new story
that gives you great pictures
with all kinds of things.
And the argument, or the
fear, or the negative vision
here is that gamification,
like the PlayPump,
is very much this.
If companies, or organizations,
or governments talking
about we're using games to
power, engage, and dah, dah,
dah, dah, dah, or when the
current administration says
we're going to put
constant [INAUDIBLE]
into to the White House Office
of Science and Technology
Office in order to run
games for brand challenges,
this is not so much because
it actually changes stuff,
but because it is, in
Elizabeth [INAUDIBLE] word,
the [INAUDIBLE].
That is it's nice sounding words
with no meaning, whose only
purpose is to appear cool
and modern as organizations.
Enough talk for me.
The rest of the talk should
be about exactly that,
or you think the proper
place in plain society has .
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
I left my water up there.
GABRIELLE TREPANIER-JOBIN:
Well, thank you.
It's very interesting
how you really
frame different kind of
rhetoric about gamification,
because that's really the way
I feel when I read the three
texts that were at the program
for today that was Zichermann's
text that was really
what you said,
like the type of rhetoric that
is very Utopian, conception
of gamification, something that
allows engagement, and so on,
and so forth.
And there was this
very distopian text
that we read about that
was a Schrape text,
and we were thinking
gamification
that was linking gamification
with control, governance,
surveyance at some extent.
And then that there
was your text,
so I don't know where you rate
yourself on the scale of utopia
and dystopia.
I felt you were in between
trying to compromise all this,
but maybe I'm wrong.
SEBASTIAN DETERDING:
Multiple things.
So A, I am aware
that I am, myself,
in place there, because
I have my own politics.
I have my own values.
I just tried to be
explicit to compensate.
Listen, this is the background
from which I'm coming.
And viewed through this
lens, this is what I see.
If you look through
a different lens,
you might see something else.
So therefore, I say, I'm
personally a bit more
interested in play than games,
although [INAUDIBLE] games
are structures that
[INAUDIBLE] place,
that they're not
unimportant as that.
But it's the same way
as you say ultimately.
It's men hammering and
hammer, hammering and nails,
but it's still nice to have
a hammer to do something
to do with [INAUDIBLE].
So even if a play's
important, and in the end
you want the hammer, but
the nail in the wall,
it's nice if you have
a game to afford play,
because that usually
makes things easier.
So in that sense,
in that spectrum,
I'm sort of in the negative.
And then definitely,
in terms of my values,
I come from virtue
ethical errors
to the [INAUDIBLE] perspective.
So the question, what
is the [INAUDIBLE]?
I just think this is my framing.
And viewed through
that framing, I
think, play presents as a
vision of how living could be
and what we should aspire to.
And other people might
have other's points.
So I wouldn't view myself
as Utopian or dystopian.
It's just I have
a view for this.
I think there is potential.
The big issue for me, as I
said, I also design [INAUDIBLE].
And parallel to
studying this stuff,
I've been running around,
doing workshops, or actually
designing work with companies,
like BMW, the motor company who
said, can you gamify for
assembly training for us?
OK.
And that drove my interest.
Is there a way of
doing this right?
Is there something we can
actually learn from games?
And I think that is the case.
It's just not what the
current popular conception
of game indication presents as
what we can learn in the case.
Those are just two
different things.
When I now come into an
executive board room,
basically three years ago,
the challenge was games?
What are you even doing?
So making people understand the
concept versus the potential.
Now the issue is banks to
immediately [INAUDIBLE]
of the concept.
That therefore, they
all have already
an existing preconception
of what this means.
Oh, fee [INAUDIBLE].
Yeah, sure.
More of that.
And then you have to
break that conception.
Say yeah, I know, but
that's also something,
but that's not what you
actually can learn from games.
So that's my perception
on this issue.
So questions?
I had a couple of
initial questions
from the text [INAUDIBLE].
I've clustered them into
three clusters for me
that we could go through.
But other questions,
as I was talking-- I'm
just starting
collecting, and then we
give them to a [INAUDIBLE]
other questions
that popped up for you.
It's late, I know.
GABRIELLE TREPANIER JOBIN:
Perhaps it's better if we group
them in categories?
SEBASTIAN DETERDING: Yeah.
I would do that.
Or if you need energy,
we can do a little game
to get the energy going.
Happy to do so.
I was serious.
GABRIELLE TREPANIER-JOBIN:
I have many questions.
SEBASTIAN DETERDING: OK.
So here's a thing.
I actually would suggest
doing that, if you're all OK.
If you don't want to, it's fine.
You can just sit
here, but in order
to get the energy up,
because it's actually late,
I suggest all of us
go out on the floor
for two minutes at most.
That's all I ask.
And again, if you don't
want to participate,
it's perfectly fine.
GABRIELLE TREPANIER-JOBIN: It's
their spontaneous reactions
to what has been said,
because it was slightly
different than what we read.
SEBASTIAN DETERDING: I know.
GABRIELLE TREPANIER JOBIN:
And perhaps that's why.
SEBASTIAN DETERDING: I know.
GABRIELLE TREPANIER-JOBIN:
We can also
ask you questions
about the readings.
SEBASTIAN DETERDING: You
can ask me all kinds.
So the three questions I
took out of the readings,
and I'll just list them as
far as I understood them,
and then you can add
ad libitum, and we'll
start a discussion about this.
The first one is just when
is a game slash gamification?
It's really this
definitional debate.
Is it still the
game [INAUDIBLE],
or is this already gamification?
Or when starts gamification
flipping through a game?
That was part of the questions.
The other one was
this yeah, yeah.
There's all this criticism
about this thing.
But what is good, as
in useful, actually
applicable learning from
games slash gamification?
So is there-- this
is all criticism.
Is there actually a way of
[INAUDIBLE] the situation
in which it can be used?
Maybe just a specific audience
and get the audience's change
based on more peole get used
to games, and stuff like that.
And the third
question is basically,
I don't know who that was.
Somebody said, can I
use that in my startup?
I know it's very
risky, but you pretend
like there's a question.
It follows from the other.
Can I use it, or
when can I use it?
When can I use it?
So those are the three.
If you feel misrepresented
or left out, let me know.
Or if you feel no,
based on this one
here, or now that
I wrote them down,
other stuff comes to your head.
So we'll just
collect a good one.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I was just curious
with the [INAUDIBLE] space
you had made earlier
between the styles.
Is there anything that exists in
the other two quadrants really?
[INAUDIBLE] something's
on the line,
but so there isn't
anything between?
SEBASTIAN DETERDING:
That's a very quick one.
Yes, there are two,
but they're outliers.
So if this was liminal-- so
basically reproducing society,
and this was
liminoid, questioning
being outside of society.
And this one here
is [INAUDIBLE].
So this is games, whether it
be [INAUDIBLE], and rules,
and feedback, and stuff.
And this is [INAUDIBLE],
so this is free play.
Everything should be Lego.
And as you said, there's
the big cluster here,
and there's the
big cluster here.
There is one cluster
here that's basically
Ian Bogost and a
couple of other people.
And then there's
this cluster here,
which would be called
industrial playfulness.
This classic procedural
rhetoric is basically
we can use games,
with a capital G
as systems to model other
broken systems in society.
This is how airport
security is programmed.
This is why
immigration's broken.
However, you make a system
in order to make an argument
and invite people
to see how the way
this game models a
piece of society.
Fits, or it doesn't fit my
mental model of that, how
that piece of society works.
And me negotiating that
clash between well,
I thought airport
security works this way.
This thing drove me that way.
How do I make sense of that?
Based on that clashing, you
start thinking about society,
and then maybe come
to a different idea
or come to criticizing yourself.
So this is basically
a version that's
deeply critic or
liminoid in its politics,
but still says let's
use games for that.
The other one in that corner,
industrial playfulness, these
are things like innovation
games or game storming.
Here's a recent [INAUDIBLE].
These are people in design
agencies like IDEO or Frog
saying, we can use the
playful activities,
ways of structuring
processes in order
to reliantly produce creativity.
The great thing about
design agencies,
and I've worked with
a couple of them
is that they can promise
enterprises to produce
innovation accountively.
You give us x amount of money.
And in y amount of weeks,
we have produced that amount
of [INAUDIBLE].
And we use playfulness.
We use yellow rooms, and
we use brainstorming,
and we do these silly design
exercises in order to do so.
That's very much used
in play, but very
much for existing structures.
Other questions?
GABRIELLE TREPANIER-JOBIN:
Well, I have one.
I wanted to talk a bit about
gamification in workplaces,
because I think that a lot of
students raise these questions
and on the forum.
In your text, in
rethinking unification,
you say that most of the
gamification practices
and workplaces disregard
the context in which people
come to play and
ignore that play is
supposed to be a voluntary act.
So you mentioned that
forcing workers to play
decreases that positive
feeling of performance,
and that having to play
in an appropriate context
can lead to
embarrassment, right?
So I think I was not the
only one to ask myself,
does it mean that gamification
techniques should never
be used in the workplaces?
Is the work context not
suitable for gamification?
Or can gamification be
optional in a workplace?
I think that Ryan--
not Ryan-- Shawn,
he had this similar question.
I don't know if you
want to elaborate on it.
AUDIENCE: Oh, yeah.
I was just disheartened reading
even a somewhat feeble attempt
to incorporate gamification--
SEBASTIAN DETERDING: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: --so as far as
the worker's reception went.
And I was wondering,
is there a way
to include playful elements,
like an opt in strategy?
Because I would
enjoy a playful work
environment, or
that sort of thing
that they see as
an electronic web.
SEBASTIAN DETERDING: OK.
I would tease out
two things there.
That is I always like to use
the technical term, autonomy,
because it has an
established meaning.
There is an established
theory behind it,
and psychology was voluntaryist,
freedom; very overdetermined
[INAUDIBLE].
This one, I use it, and then
I point to a certain theory,
and that's why I prefer that
term and to talk about this.
And autonomy is
still a muddled mess,
in terms of work life and games.
Can we go to that?
And then the second one,
can we learn from games
in the work place in general?
So disregarding the
voluntaryist issue,
are there ways in which we could
make life and work anonymous?
Let's speak about the
autonomy one first.
There is this interesting
early book, Julian Dibbell,
games journalist who
now became a lawyer.
Before time, he was a great
journalist in the late '90s,
looking at all the online games
craze, and he wrote a book.
Rape in Cyberspace, and
all these kind of books.
So it was in plain
money, how he basically
made a living with designing
virtual [INAUDIBLE] space.
And he noticed he was one of
the first Western observers
who sold gold farmers.
For those who are not
familiar with the term,
gold farmers are basically
people, supposedly always
Chinese gold farmers.
And then there
are other articles
saying that's stereotyping,
because we also
find in other places--
anyhow, Chinese gold farmers
are people who level up
characters or win virtual items
in games for a living.
And so I gain a powerful
sword in World of Warcraft,
and then I sell it
to other people.
And usually, these kind of gold
farmers themselves don't do it,
but it's other people
hiring poor people
off the street in China,
young people to basically play
World of Warcraft.
It's day by day, and day in, day
out in 20 hour shifts or more,
and just sleep.
They go back and
play as a waged war.
So the more gold you
play, the [INAUDIBLE]
played for the virtual
gold in real money, which
is a classic form of peace work
which other people, if you've
ever done peace work in
an actual assembly line,
so you know that's pretty
excruciating as an activity.
And he found two weird things.
A, he said, they were playing.
They were working in this game.
And according to
standard theory,
the should have hated
every minute of it,
working this game.
But it seemed pretty
playful at times.
At times, it also
seems pretty stressed.
But at times, they were still
playful in that context.
And then he said
the weirdest thing
is when they handed
the day off, they
would hop into the
internet cafe next door
and play games-- the same games.
And so how can
that-- I'm puzzled.
I can't even make a story
to begin to make sense.
Why would they do
the thing voluntarily
that they were
forced to do there?
Why would the forced thing
sometimes still be fun to them?
And the part of the
argument, or part
of the way that
you psychologically
can tease that out
is say that autonomy
has a lot to do with
your internal perception
of the situation.
That is if in the
moment you feel
like this is what I
want to do, I currently
feel like doing this.
And so therefore, I enjoy this.
This is what I want to do.
You don't have to force
yourself to do it.
It feels like this is a
true expression of yourself.
And so therefore,
it feels autonomous.
if you go to a cloister
for a six week retreat,
and somebody tells you at 6:00
AM in the morning, get up.
Sweet the stairs, because
that's part of your retreat.
If you then think about
I actually put myself
into this oyster, and
I want to do this,
and I know it's a good thing--
you might still go-- mm.
But you feel this is an
expression of yourself,
and you still feel
that certainly this
is a voluntary act.
This is still an autonomous act.
And you might still find
a way of getting absorbed
in the activity of
[INAUDIBLE], and then
you forget the fact that
you're actually tired.
So the degree to which
I perceive myself
that this is currently
an outflow of my goals,
wants, and my
identity is chiefly
responsible to whether this
is autonomous or not for me,
as an experience, which is
something that [INAUDIBLE]
and [INAUDIBLE],
author of [INAUDIBLE].
One of the core books in
game studies [INAUDIBLE]
has found where he said
even in concentration camps,
people could be absorbed
in the activity.
People could feel a degree
of control, voluntarism
in autonomy, because
they chose how
to deal with the task that
were prescribed to them.
Even if they work
for the [INAUDIBLE]
that lent in their
ultimate demise.
So it's this what
internal stance do
I take to what's my situation?
So it's not that because
workplace, therefore,
obligatory context,
that are therefore
necessary in autonomous.
It's how do I
perceive this to be
an outflow of my personal self?
And there's been
research, especially
in education how people can
facilitate an autonomous
orientation towards an activity,
even in the mandatory context,
like school.
There's stuff teachers can do
to tell the students, listen.
I know the next
exercise is shitty.
Sorry for that.
Here is why doing this is still
useful and helpful for you
personally.
And I would ask you to do it,
because it's helpful for you;
asking permission,
explaining why,
acknowledging that it's
tedious-- all these giving me
free options how
to do it, with whom
to do it, how to
approach the problem;
lots of ways in which
you can structure
an obligatory situation to
still be autonomous [INAUDIBLE].
So it's a complicated
psychological thing
that has a lot to
do with what is
my internal stance towards it?
But there's a lot
of design things
around the social
situations we still can do,
which leads us to
the second thing.
Is there things we can
learn from games in order
to make a work
environment playful?
As I said, with the sleds, I
looked into their research,
because I was invited to
give a talk at a conference
about office furniture.
They wanted to gamify
office furniture.
Sure.
And so I looked
into the whole thing
and said, how do people gamify
offices and office furniture?
And notice that it's actually a
big trend, the playful office.
And if I say playful office,
just what are you thinking?
What images jumps to your mind?
Playful office.
AUDIENCE: Google.
SEBASTIAN DETERDING: Google.
AUDIENCE: Nerf
guns in the office.
SEBASTIAN DETERDING:
Nerf guns in the office.
What else?
AUDIENCE: Ping pong?
SEBASTIAN DETERDING: Ping pong?
AUDIENCE: Ping
pong in the office.
SEBASTIAN DETERDING:
Ping pong in the office.
Yes, what else?
AUDIENCE: Insert fun
thing in the office.
Bean bag chairs and other
horrible-for-your-back
furniture.
SEBASTIAN DETERDING: Yeah.
What else?
Playful office, just off
the top of your head.
AUDIENCE: Free food everywhere.
AUDIENCE: Weird looking,
ergonomic furniture.
SEBASTIAN DETERDING: Not working
around my furniture, free food
everywhere, plants.
Yeah, plants are totally
important, even fake plants.
AUDIENCE: Scooters.
SEBASTIAN DETERDING:
Scooters, yes.
AUDIENCE: Friendly bosses.
SEBASTIAN DETERDING:
Friendly bosses?
Then we're getting
into different topics.
Yeah, exactly.
AUDIENCE: Very scary
company open work spaces
without cubicles.
SEBASTIAN DETERDING:
Yes, open work spaces.
The weird thing
about cubicles is
in terms of their
design history,
their point was to be free.
Back in the 1960s,
people started
working on designing
the cubicle,
and their point was to actually
create playful architecture.
Their point was to make
this is a way in which
individual workers,
without big effort,
could continue to redesign
the office to their own needs.
They would just take
the balls and rearrange
them to huddle their space
as they see fit for a project
or for individual close time.
Only then the corporations
discovered hey,
we can also use
cubicles to give people
a bit of sound,
and visual privacy,
and cram the most possible
people into the smallest
possible space.
Cubicles where initially
invented in order
to be a more free
and open office
work, and then they would reuse
the floor very differently,
which points to
an important part
this is what you put in there
as a design element is often not
so important as how
people use it in practice.
The practice is the way in which
people live something is just
as important as the things
you put into the office,
like bean bags.
So no.
All of these things are true.
Bean bags usually will find
everything that screams
playground; bright colors.
AUDIENCE: Slides.
SEBASTIAN DETERDING:
Slides, natural textures.
So you have fake
grass, real grass.
You have sand.
You have round shapes.
There will always
be round shapes
and all these kind of things--
things that look playful.
But structurally, if you ask
yourself what makes a toy?
What makes a good toy, or
the opposite of a good toy.
What makes a good toy?
Any suggestions?
What are toys that
you actually enjoy
toying around for a long,
long, long time ago?
Mhm?
AUDIENCE: Call of Duty?
SEBASTIAN DETERDING:
That's a game.
A toy.
Call of Duty can
be used as a toy.
We'll get to that.
AUDIENCE: Simple,
multi-purpose objects?
Kickballs, and shopping
lists, and buckets, and stuff
like that?
SEBASTIAN DETERDING: Yeah.
Wide shock.
GABRIELLE TREPANIER-JOBIN:
It stimulates creativity?
AUDIENCE: Because you can use
it for more than one thing.
SEBASTIAN DETERDING: You can
use it for more than one thing.
AUDIENCE: Because when
a teacher's not looking,
I could hit people with it.
But if it's still the other
stuff with it, [INAUDIBLE]
like oh.
SEBASTIAN DETERDING:
Other suggestions?
AUDIENCE: Nothing.
Nerf gun?
SEBASTIAN DETERDING: Why?
AUDIENCE: It's fun.
SEBASTIAN DETERDING:
What makes Nerf guns fun?
AUDIENCE: Give it to
a couple of people.
SEBASTIAN DETERDING: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And then it
becomes fun, all of a sudden.
[LAUGHTER]
SEBASTIAN DETERDING: Again,
Nerf gun, as such, is not fun.
Fun is when the people actually
decide to go around and--
AUDIENCE: Oh, I see.
I see.
SEBASTIAN DETERDING:
And I would say
the Nerf gun invites people
to actually temporarily go out
of bounds and go out
of their regular rules.
So a lot of playing--
AUDIENCE: I was going
to say a Barbie doll.
SEBASTIAN DETERDING:
Barbie doll.
Why Barbie doll?
AUDIENCE: Because you could
basically do whatever you want.
You could play house with it.
You can make up a story with it.
You could act out going to work.
You can pretend that your
Barbie doll's having a wedding.
[INAUDIBLE] sort of thing.
AUDIENCE: I think it totally
solves the blank canvas
problem that involved-- if I
say I want to play something,
but I have nothing
in front of me,
I'm not going to be inspired
to do anything necessarily.
But if I have a toy, [INAUDIBLE]
it's a Barbie doll, oh.
It's a person.
I can pretend it's a person.
I can play like it's a person.
Or a Nerf gun gives
me, oh, it's a gun.
I can pretend it's a gun.
It gives me something
to work on though.
SEBASTIAN DETERDING: Mhm.
AUDIENCE: It's like
modular things.
It's like those K'nex.
SEBASTIAN DETERDING: Yep.
AUDIENCE: Little sheets, and
marbles, and things like that.
SEBASTIAN DETERDING: Yeah.
You teased out
very successfully,
the two [INAUDIBLE].
The one thing is it
involved a purpose.
It's underspecified.
It doesn't prescribe
one specific way
in which [INAUDIBLE].
Think about Fisher Price
will often [INAUDIBLE] toys.
They're the worst
possible toys imaginable.
They just have a
number of buttons,
and then you hit the button.
It makes a certain sound, or
it flashes a certain light.
And I discovered yeah,
that button always
produces that light.
That button always
produces that sound
until it becomes a social
experiment where you only
try to find out which
is the button that
annoys mom and dad [INAUDIBLE]?
That's fun.
The thing itself is
not necessarily fun,
so it's underspecified.
There are loads of different
things you can do with them,
and you can explore this
possibility space, which
is the possibly of space
in Legos, or in Barbies,
or in any other thing.
And in addition, it gives you a
constraint or a starting point.
It's not just a blank canvas.
It gives you a seed
for the exploration
of that [INAUDIBLE], whereas
most of these other spaces,
or like Fisher Price
toys [INAUDIBLE].
They look playful.
Colors, [INAUDIBLE] sleds.
But they are not an
underspecified possibility
space.
They are not things that you
can use in very many ways that
invite you to reuse,
and abuse, and jump
over existing [INAUDIBLE] how to
use this thing as you see fit.
And if you look into what
acclimates [INAUDIBLE] office
architecture, you find
stuff like actually, what's
the building-- building 20?
The historically famous
building where most of the MIT
innovations that you
were involved with--
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Quite a different [INAUDIBLE].
SEBASTIAN DETERDING:
Yeah, exactly.
That building.
And when [INAUDIBLE],
some people here at MIT,
looked at what made that
thing such an incubator, apart
from the fact that it was
a collision space for lots
of people in
different disciplines,
they had no way but to bump
into each other the whole time.
The second thing is
it was a barrack.
And it was such a
run down barrack
that nobody cared if
you wanted to have
this big machine in there that
took three floors that you just
[INAUDIBLE] your balls
through, forced through,
which was that
everybody was doing it.
It was a modulous case that
everybody deems as they
see fit for weird things.
So the question, can we
learn from games for office
work to make it playful?
Well, if one of the
things that invites play
is an open possibility
space for exploration
where I get to choose
where it's autonomy
supported, because I have a
lot of choices what to do.
Give me an office space
that works like that.
Give me working rules
that are like that,
like results only
work environments.
I don't prescribe to
you how you do it.
I give you a goal, and you
choose who you want to do it,
how you want to
do it, et cetera .
If you feel that is too
little structure for you,
then the good game
designer would give you
a bit of scaffolding
and say, then
come back to me as a supervisor,
and I give you a tip.
But other than that, go out.
Just come back when
you have it done.
That would be one
of the many ways
you can learn from
games that are not
about having a feedback system.
AUDIENCE: I play a
lot of games, and we
move towards implementing trying
to make an exterior to the game
economist and things like
that, and trademark [INAUDIBLE]
exteriorly, and start to model
the real world in that sense.
What do you think
about a lot of that?
I think you gave it as the other
half of the equation, where you
take the real world into
the game, so to speak,
where people now
dish on commodities,
and so a form of betting is
they can't bet real world items.
SEBASTIAN DETERDING:
It's interesting.
It's the point where I
am then the sociologist,
and you start to notice.
We have certain cultural notions
about what games all should be,
a traditionally
modern notion, which
is this leisure time activity.
It's voluntary.
You can't gain or
lose anything by it.
The moment you do
that, it's gambling.
It's not really gaming.
That's a different thing,
gambling and gaming,
although the gambling
industry, because of that
always wants to say, no, no.
Gambling is gaming.
But culturally, we
make that distinction
to say the moment there
is something at stake,
it's not really gaming anymore.
And the interesting thing
with all of these things
is that it basically upturns
existing institutionalizations
of how games
traditionally happen.
And then people look
at this thing and say,
how the heck are we going
to make sense of this?
And how the heck are we going
to regulate it, or legislate
it, and what's right,
and what's wrong?
So first of all, I just
find it interesting,
because like every other
media convergence phenomenon,
it just throws existing
orders into relief,
and then people have to
scramble through the mess.
What else I make of
the-- it's the same
as freemium games, where you pay
for in game advancements, where
a lot of them, the
traditional triple [INAUDIBLE]
says no, no, no, no, no, no.
This is dirty.
This is evil.
You bring economic things into
our shiny, pristine little
temples where
economics has no place.
And then as terrible as the
concept of the magic circle
is, what they're
basically describing
is in the old AAA
industry economic model,
they play games,
the Call of Duties,
money was admittance and
allowed into that game space.
But when I'm in the game
space, money has no role.
In the freemium world, you
get into the game for free.
And then to get ahead, within
the game, sometimes you
have to pay money.
It's just a different way in
which money factors into game
play.
It's just that most people
are used to this model
and say game play should be free
from economic considerations.
Only it hasn't
been for AAA games
either, because AAA
games traditionally,
because of the kind of
business models they have,
were built such that they
gave great tradeoff for it,
because that's the way you get
a lot of people to do this.
AAA games are
notoriously risk averse.
You just get Call of Duty
24/7, and the next version,
the next version,
or the next version.
Why?
Because traditional AAA games
are so investment intensive;
dozens of millions of
dollars, that the people who
give the money say,
the only way we
know we're going to
recoup our investments
is due to the very
same recipe-- again,
that we did before where
we reduce the risk.
So in that sense,
money influences
what happens within the game as
well, just in a different way,
and in a way people are not used
to, and people scream murder.
There are then different things
with [INAUDIBLE] I would ask
is that do I like that
aesthetically or not?
That's a different [INAUDIBLE].
Based on my personal,
ethical evaluation,
do I think certain ways
of free to play games
are organized in
a nice way or not?
And I would also say no, but
it's the same phenomenon.
Mhm?
AUDIENCE: So I know you
talk about using people
or [INAUDIBLE] to [INAUDIBLE]
you hide within games,
and then you turn
around and sell that.
What about games
or situations where
you end up making
a lot of money,
but not really intending to?
Like you're still
out there playing
the game even online or
something and you find items,
or you acquire assets that
are then worth a lot of money.
SEBASTIAN DETERDING: Mhm.
AUDIENCE: And games like Dodo 2
and TF2 that now, [INAUDIBLE].
So people sell characters after
a point, and then [INAUDIBLE].
SEBASTIAN DETERDING: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You play
through a game,
you get past a certain
point of aggression.
You cite your character,
and statutes like that.
Or like he was saying,
recent games like Dodo
and Counter-Strike, a lot
of the battle games, where
they try the policy
that you can get drops
that are worth large amounts of
money by simply playing a game.
AUDIENCE: So they're not
necessarily purposely farming
for items, but being aware
that that's a possibility,
and that also being part of
the [INAUDIBLE] proclaim.
AUDIENCE: Right.
From the outset I would say,
whatever floats your boat.
If you, as an individual
say that's something
that I enjoy doing,
or that's something
that I want to do for
all kinds of reasons,
then feel free to do so.
So to what extent is
that then still a game?
Or is it a game that I play is
an interesting question, which
basically brings us to
when is the game a game,
or when is the game
a gamification?
The first thing I would do is
as long as I, as an individual,
play this predominantly
in order to have fun,
it fits the regular mold
of how we would say that.
Incidentally, in the end, you
find that the exhaust of what
you can do, you
can also set off.
It's just oh.
At that point, it's nice,
interesting, and weird.
So let's try and explicate
this one here, actually.
Just shout out.
When is something a game?
What are the conditions
that have to--
or how to determine
whether something
is a game or [INAUDIBLE]?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I think
that the biggest
thing is the voluntary playing.
So it's a game if
it's voluntary.
SEBASTIAN DETERDING:
Voluntary, OK.
AUDIENCE: A reward system?
SEBASTIAN DETERDING: OK.
If it has a reward
system, it's a game.
If it doesn't, it's not a game?
AUDIENCE: Not
necessarily, right?
SEBASTIAN DETERDING:
I'm asking you.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
SEBASTIAN DETERDING: You
suggested a reward system.
I'm just asking.
AUDIENCE: I think it
is not unique to games,
but games should definitely
have a reward system.
SEBASTIAN DETERDING: They
should have one because--
AUDIENCE: Well,
what's the incentive?
There should be
one behind a game.
So it may be a feeling that
you're getting smarter,
or maybe you're getting points.
Or solving a puzzle.
There should be something
that is captivating you.
But the reward system-- when
you walk in doing your job,
and you're getting paid for
it, it's also a reward system.
So I feel like it's
not unique to games,
but games should definitely
offer a reward system.
SEBASTIAN DETERDING: OK.
Is voluntarynism
unique to games?
GABRIELLE TREPANIER-JOBIN: No.
AUDIENCE: No.
SEBASTIAN DETERDING: I can cook
for the enjoyment of cooking.
So we were playing
a game outside.
Did you get a reward for that in
your understanding of a reward?
AUDIENCE: It may not be
something as trivial as hey,
just get plus one point
or plus two points.
But definitely, you
could bond with people.
SEBASTIAN DETERDING: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So yes,
it was a reward.
SEBASTIAN DETERDING: OK.
So I'm just making
sure that you're--
AUDIENCE: Besides the
energy of waking up--
SEBASTIAN DETERDING: Yeah.
I'm just saying that your way
of understanding the reward here
is something that is
not necessarily tied
to a reward system.
As you do x number of things,
you get the x number of points
translatable into the y
number with something else.
So the suggestion is
you award [INAUDIBLE]
broccoli as there
is a desired result,
however you want to
construe the desired result.
That's like economists say
preferences, which basically
means everything [INAUDIBLE].
Mhm?
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
Are we just saying when
is something a game?
Or are we trying
to differentiate
between when it's a game
and when it's gamification?
SEBASTIAN DETERDING: We'll
get the gamification.
Now it's just when
is something a game?
AUDIENCE: OK.
Because then voluntary
is not [INAUDIBLE],
because I was thinking
of it in terms of--
SEBASTIAN DETERDING: Ah.
AUDIENCE: --is it a
game or a gamification?
SEBASTIAN DETERDING:
So a game is voluntary.
Gamification is [INAUDIBLE],
or the other way around.
Why?
AUDIENCE: Because gamification
is more of a system
that I guess you could
choose to be part of it.
So if you go to a
weird place that does
have a game like culture, or
you're choosing to do that.
But then you could
also inevitably end up
in a gamification culture
where you don't-- if everything
becomes like that, or you
don't want to be in it.
But a game, like say
video games are playing.
I could have refrained from
going outside and playing tag.
So it wasn't a voluntary action.
SEBASTIAN DETERDING: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I don't know if I
agree that it's necessarily not
voluntary.
SEBASTIAN DETERDING: OK.
AUDIENCE: So I think that games
are that may be non-voluntary,
but then gamification,
something like it's
a game if I just play sports
because I enjoy playing sports.
But if I'm playing
soccer because I
want to get the
statistics on my Fitbit
or my pace counter for
my health insurance,
then it's gamification.
SEBASTIAN DETERDING: What
about professional sports?
Like I play soccer, because
I earn $5 million a year
for playing soccer.
And if I know if I
lose that next game,
I won't win that marketing
contract [INAUDIBLE].
I really have to play
well at this game.
Is that then, still a game?
Or is it gamification?
Or is it something else?
AUDIENCE: I can't play.
AUDIENCE: I could,
and that goes back
to what you're saying about
the economy, [INAUDIBLE].
If you say, it's
really cool that I get
paid to do what I love, yeah.
I think it's cool.
I have tons of money.
But also it [INAUDIBLE] like
if you pay me half as much,
I would still do it.
SEBASTIAN DETERDING: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I would still
enjoy this as much,
then it's more of a game.
SEBASTIAN DETERDING: So it's
voluntarynist less in terms
of the empirical conditions,
or you pay the amount.
It's voluntarynism
more then in terms
of how do I perceive
myself as I do this thing?
Which isn't important
at some point.
AUDIENCE: I feel
that my time would
be better used doing something
else when it's a game.
It's pretty useless.
SEBASTIAN DETERDING: Ah.
That's interesting.
So a game has to be a
waste, is it, in some way.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
professional player,
you have to make more
money [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Really?
What are you going to do?
AUDIENCE: Like look
at it honestly.
Aside from some of the most
recent tournaments and things
like that where they've
actually stepped up [INAUDIBLE],
but a lot of that--
AUDIENCE: Like football
players, right?
AUDIENCE: So yeah, you're
stepping [INAUDIBLE].
Some might say conventional
sports, and things like that,
But what's your chances
of making it there?
AUDIENCE: Well, I'm saying,
if you're Tom Brady,
you're not making any more
money doing anything else.
It's a horrible example.
Brady keeps taking pay cuts.
Man, [INAUDIBLE].
You're not going to get any
more money doing something else,
but it's still something
they find [INAUDIBLE].
Does that mean they don't
think of it like a game?
I don't know.
That steps into the
same space that we
were just at before where we're
asking a question of if you're
playing a sport, because that's
what makes you all the money,
and it's almost no longer
in your own choice to do it,
because this is the
best possible option
for your utility.
You make more money doing this.
You're Tiger Woods.
You make more money by playing
golf than mowing your own lawn.
So naturally, you pay somebody
else to mow your own lawn.
Well, at a certain
point in time,
you make the most
money by being filmed
as if you were playing golf.
AUDIENCE: I really disagree
with calling the game a waste.
SEBASTIAN DETERDING: Sure.
AUDIENCE: And if I were to
tweet that out right now to Anna
Anthropy, she would kill me.
AUDIENCE: Fair enough.
AUDIENCE: People don't generally
consider reading a book
or reading a newspaper
article a waste.
But there are a
lot of games that
are like the equivalent
of doing that.
Like Anna Anthropy's
games, pretty much just
all of her games.
Or like Squinkies
games are all very--
they're meant to
teach you something
a lot more than the
bottom right hand corner.
AUDIENCE: So I would
say the idea of it being
a waste can be more voluntary.
I'm not playing
this game because I
need to do it to finish
a graduation requirement.
I'm playing this game, because
it's a recreational thing.
So in some sense,
it's like games
can be a waste so that's
a really negative turn,
but that gamification is usually
framed into this is a.k.a.
You should be doing, because its
ulterior motive is [INAUDIBLE].
The market is something
that has to be
valuable in some other context
than just the enjoyment
of the experience.
like you're being more fit or
learning more about something.
SEBASTIAN DETERDING: You're
just describing the reverse case
of what they were
actually-- a couple
of nice [INAUDIBLE] experiments
about in the younger learning.
In fact, when people
say if you give somebody
a reward for doing
that, they will later on
reconstrue why
they did something.
Oh, it was a good reward.
Therefore, it cannot be
something that I should do
for its own sake, just
because I enjoy doing it.
Or therefore, maybe I didn't
do it for its own sake.
So next time, I should
expect [INAUDIBLE] for that
so I'm less motivated to
do it without a motivation
the next time.
So if you add an extrinsic
reward [INAUDIBLE],
it becomes less
motivated to begin with,
because you underline
the perception
of autonomy of the description
[INAUDIBLE] to begin with.
Whereas if you say well, if
it's really wasteful, if I
say there's nothing that
comes out of it reliably,
I can look at the
situation and say,
well if it's really
wasteful, the only reason
why I may do this is because
I enjoy the [INAUDIBLE];
not because I'm getting
a reward for that.
Ergo, this is an activity
that I'm really [INAUDIBLE].
Therefore, if it's
very autonomous,
[INAUDIBLE], this is something
where I fully just-- this
comes to us out of my own
personal beliefs, wishes,
and goals, nothing else.
Or you could use the Calvinist
version of that saying,
this is a waste.
I shouldn't do this.
And by the fact
that I put myself
against the moral tub of a
Calvinist culture around me
that always wants
to be productive,
and so I intentionally
[INAUDIBLE] completely wasteful
to show you that I'm
not always controlled
by your damn culture.
In the same way, you are
reinserting your autonomy
by doing something intentionally
[INAUDIBLE], potentially.
So yes, they're definitely
in these psychological ways,
intertwined.
AUDIENCE: I'm curious if that
means the example we said where
they were being paid
to play the game,
but then they also played
it in their days off.
SEBASTIAN DETERDING: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Then would it be
a game when they played it
on during their free time,
but it's gamification
when they do it as a job?
The same exact game,
with the same exact,
enjoyment for the
person playing it?
SEBASTIAN DETERDING:
It's a good question,
but I'll get to that
in one second please.
AUDIENCE: I think it's worth
unpacking the word game,
and that we're using it
in two different senses.
I think you might have just
said there is the people who
are planning to play
the game for work,
and then play the game for play.
But when they're playing a game
outside of the context of work,
I think they might see it
as I am playing a game right
now, whereas that other
thing they are playing,
this game-- how
do I describe it?
There's a difference
between the game
that everyone calls a game, this
program system that everyone
plays, and the activity of
the person actually playing
the game.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] as
a subset of [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Right.
Gold farming is a thing
you can do in this system
that we call a game, because
people tend to play it.
In that case, there
are ways of playing
the game that don't meet
that normal expectation
and might look like work.
And then there's the normal way
of playing the game that they
return to on their own time that
perhaps is more fun and less
for this external reward.
SEBASTIAN DETERDING: Yep.
That is a very important one,
and one that is especially
in game study is
usually completed
that is the distinction between
object and activity [INAUDIBLE]
of engagement.
Because [INAUDIBLE] like to
say well, if I'm the toddler,
I have no concept
of game theory.
I haven't been
socialized into games,
and I accidentally happen to
hack under the chess computer,
entering the exact commands
that are legal commands based
on the rules of chess.
Is the toddler playing chess?
Or is the toddler toying around
with the chess set, [INAUDIBLE]
the concept of what playing
the game of chess means?
No, but those are free.
Give the toddler
his [INAUDIBLE].
I'm trying to play chess here.
In the same way, if I'm
the usability engineer,
and I am clicking my way
through Halo in order
to [INAUDIBLE]
usability products.
Am I playing Halo?
Or am I testing Halo?
The activity that
I'm engaged in--
and this is actually
the court subject,
what was the subject matter of
my PhD research [INAUDIBLE],
for exactly that
kind of experience.
The activity that
they're engaged in
is testing, even though the
object they're operating with
is a game.
So keeping these two
separate you could say well,
it was the game.
But maybe some points,
when they felt oh, now I'm
engaged in World of Warcraft
in order to make money,
they felt this feels
like-- it's still
game play, what I do, but
it's game play as work.
It's game play reorganized,
reframed as working to me.
So it's not really
playing the game anymore.
It's work playing.
It's a weird mixture.
It's a new type of
activity, but it's not
playing as we know
leisure time [INAUDIBLE].
So that's definitely an
important distinction.
The second thing,
or the final thing
that I want to turn on, in terms
of when it is something a game
or a gamification?
First thing to notice--
all of this was tested,
and you could throw
in new points,
and you would get it to
the same [INAUDIBLE];
yes, no, yes, no, yes, no.
So how do we know if a term is
correctly used for something
or not?
What determines whether
a word is currently
used within the device
[INAUDIBLE] or not?
When is something
correctly called oxygen?
When is correctly or incorrectly
identified as oxygen?
AUDIENCE: Shouldn't all
these depend on the context?
SEBASTIAN DETERDING: How so?
AUDIENCE: Because if you
just give it time by itself,
without much context, you
can actually figure out
if it is correctly used or not.
So for example, oxygen, just
given the word like that,
I can say something like we
all need oxygen to break.
SEBASTIAN DETERDING: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: But then
you can also say
something else like too much
oxygen can asphyxiate us.
SEBASTIAN DETERDING: Mhm.
AUDIENCE: Actually,
is that true?
[LAUGHTER]
SEBASTIAN DETERDING:
I see what you mean.
So definitely, whether a
statement using the word
is correct or not depends
on the total statement.
Totally.
Second point is so when
is the term correctly used
or incorrectly used?
How do we determine if the
term's correctly or incorrectly
used to identifying something--
a phenomenon, an object
in the world, [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: I would say it's
really hard to do that.
And there's a reason.
It's like oxygen,
everyone's thinking here.
It's also the name
of a TV channel.
SEBASTIAN DETERDING: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And that's
fully correct.
It just felt like that.
So I think the context of what
you were saying is important.
So when you wrote that word
down and asked that question,
the answer was what
you were thinking of,
because it was in the
context that you have.
So we would have to figure
out what context you
were talking about and then
answer that question correctly.
But someone else could come
up and ask the same question
with a different context,
and the answer would change.
And you could make this
argument for almost every word.
That's part of the
reason why it's
really hard to get computers
to understand what humans are
talking about, because
you have to give them
this conflict and the context.
So I don't know if you can
for sure define something
like that.
I may run around with a
different [INAUDIBLE].
SEBASTIAN DETERDING: OK.
If you ask a
scientist, a chemist,
how do I identify whether
something's correctly
or incorrectly called oxygen?
How do you go about that?
AUDIENCE: And at
that point, you claim
that there's some fundamental
principle of the object as such
that you can identify about it
that identifies it as oxygen.
And so you can concoct some
series of tests that allow you
to verify the things
that make it as such,
because you have
some set of rules.
You verified against
all the rules,
and you claim that therefore,
this thing's oxygen.
SEBASTIAN DETERDING:
Scientists that
basically were
chemists in that case,
have operationalized
that concept.
Or the other way
around the concept
is defined by the very
set of operationalization.
So if it passes these
tests, it counts as oxygen.
That's how we define that term.
So that's the
definition [INAUDIBLE],
which works great for
scientific constructs,
if that's how scientific
concepts work basically.
Now, what about
something like delicious?
When do I know whether
the word delicious
is correctly or incorrectly used
to apply it to a given object?
AUDIENCE: Isn't that
extremely subjective?
AUDIENCE: That's
correct, and identify
against everybody in the
room and prove to them
that that's delicious.
SEBASTIAN DETERDING:
[JOKINGLY] It is delicious
when I tell you.
Right.
It's a subjective term.
Delicious isn't true
or untrue based on
whether it passes
a number of tests.
Delicious is an expression of
a subjective value experience.
If I find it delicious, I
can use the term delicious.
It would be incorrectly used
if I used the word delicious,
although I think this is
their choice [INAUDIBLE],
but it's delicious
for me or not.
What about as a
kind of middle term?
It's not a middle term.
This mixes all kinds of things.
What about something
like faux pas?
A social faux pas or
inappropriateness-- something
like that.
When is the words
inappropriate and so faux pas
appropriately used?
AUDIENCE: It both depends on the
context and if it's subjective.
SEBASTIAN DETERDING:
How is it subjective?
AUDIENCE: In France, something
might be illegal, or in the US,
it is not.
SEBASTIAN DETERDING: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And depending on
the context of the thing,
of what happened, then
even in the same country
or same location with
the same set of rules,
it might be good
or bad, depending
on who is the person
actually looking at it.
SEBASTIAN DETERDING: Mhm.
So I flush that out.
It's something that we have,
like a formal definition
to the way that it works.
There's a set of
[INAUDIBLE] rules you're
supposed to adhere to, a
way that the context has
been misinterpreted, or
something of that nature.
It's like using the word
irony, or something like that.
There's a specific
formula for how you
know something is [INAUDIBLE].
But past that, there's
also still the fact
that you have
identify it as such,
and that's dependent on the
context or the situation
you read that inside of, because
what it is in one situation may
not be in another.
And it's definitely
my situation.
It's highly situation dependent
on [INAUDIBLE] culturally.
How to properly or
improperly [INAUDIBLE]
taken that into the business
partisan [INAUDIBLE]
different depending on
the different cultures.
I do this usually to
how people think about--
if you'd look at
a certain concept,
is this more like a
scientific construct?
Is this more like a
subjective value statement,
or is this more a
social convention?
And I would say games
and gamification,
because they weren't around
before people were around.
But it's still something
that we use as a sure term to
[INAUDIBLE].
And don't think that somebody
can say for me, this is a game.
For me, this is not a game.
Like you would say for
me, this is delicious.
For me, this is not
delicious, that it's basically
the social convention
[INAUDIBLE].
This is this sure
cultural sense of this
is what a game is
or shouldn't be.
So to an extent, teasing out
when is the game, or when
is not a game.
What you're doing
here is basically
you're doing social linguistics.
You're teasing out what are
the conventions of a shared
community of people
what they consider
to be a proper game or not?
And then you run into
all the [INAUDIBLE]
cases where the language
community in front of you.
And you hear people say, is
that a game I don't know?
That's weird.
That's odd.
It doesn't fit my prototype
case of how games should be.
And gamification
presents us with all
of these cases for
real money trading
and stuff like that that,
[INAUDIBLE] all these cases
that don't fit our
existing social conventions
of the category of gamers.
And so therefore, we
have all [INAUDIBLE],
because their
challenge-- they're
an empirically new
phenomenon that
don't fit our existing
conceptual categories.
I was [INAUDIBLE]
existing categories.
So to a certain extent
when is it games,
or when is it gamification?
Let's see how society solidifies
opinion around these terms.
Right now, it's up in the
air, to a certain extent.
Or that's what I suggest, so
that's what I sometimes do.
If I introduce an
article I say, I'm not
doing social [INAUDIBLE] here.
I'm not trying to tease up
what people think collectively,
the way they police
language together,
whether this is a game
or not, or whether this
is an unsettled
matter [INAUDIBLE].
I use it as a
scientific construct,
and here is my
operationalization
of that scientific construct.
I use the term [INAUDIBLE].
It is supposed to mean that it's
to pass the following tests.
And if it fits these
tests, it is gamification.
If it doesn't fit
these tests, it's game.
You can disagree with that.
You can make up another
operationalization.
But in that sense, the
meaning of the word
is I use it in
[INAUDIBLE] of this text.
Another interesting
thing in a second.
thing is that
is this still a game
or not, or is this this
or that is that
you often conflict
normative and
descriptive [INAUDIBLE].
This isn't a game.
If you look at
[INAUDIBLE], it very often
just means this is
not a game I'm liking.
It doesn't mean that it doesn't
fit the descriptive categories
that you can say, according
to this game theoretician,
it's set up list
the five defining
criteria of whether
it's a game or not.
It fits the bill, but it's
not a kind of game I'm liking.
So if we say, is this still
a game or gamification
it often says is this
a certain kind of game
that I like versus the certain
kind that I dislike, Dido?
AUDIENCE: So if we're
talking, in regards
to the more subjective
view of this distinction,
I was wondering if you
think whether or not
a person looking at you for a
game or a [INAUDIBLE] context,
whether or not if they
identify as the gamer,
or if they had prior
experience with even
more traditional games will
effect their typecasting of
whether or not it's a
game or a gamification.
Will people who are
more familiar with games
recognize things
that are more subtle
and say oh, that's
gamification faster?
Or is it they're more
accustomed to it?
They won't see it
as much, and just
wondering the different-- that
would be like me or my mother
basically.
SEBASTIAN DETERDING:
There are lots
of interesting [INAUDIBLE].
A, there is beginning data,
especially when people
do gamification [INAUDIBLE].
We find old people play games.
They just don't
play video games.
They play board games,
card games, social games,
all kinds of games.
It's not as if they were not
introduced to the concept.
But they don't know the video
game lexicon [INAUDIBLE]
necessarily.
So they don't know
progress bars.
They don't know achievements.
And so it's all of
that [INAUDIBLE].
What's that then?
What happens now?
And I remember a
former girlfriend
of mine, the first
time she played.
[INAUDIBLE] obviously,
there were achievements.
She was in the achievements
screen and say,
the game is broken.
How do I get back?
She wasn't absolutely not
introduced to the concept.
And as gamification
for the elderly
do is they show
data that indicates
there is another nice little
identification in the work
place by [INAUDIBLE]
molecule a bit
that [INAUDIBLE], that people
who are socialized into games
tend to pick up gamification
more easily or usually
a bit more lenient
towards it, whereas people
who don't have a
game of socialization
are more [INAUDIBLE].
The second [INAUDIBLE].
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: This is going to
sound really stupid coming out
of my mouth, but are games
these days gamified in the sense
that so it takes me to
the achievement system.
That wasn't in games that
should go back in time?
SEBASTIAN DETERDING: Yep.
AUDIENCE: And now
you see that it's now
almost a requisite part of
any game that comes out.
A game doesn't come out
without achieving things.
A shooting game doesn't come
without her filling health
bars, and fields,
and things like that.
These tropes that define
the topic itself necessarily
comes reflexible with
[INAUDIBLE] on it,
and it's pointless
to describe things
as gamified and everything.
Both games and non-games
can have that slim set
of [INAUDIBLE].
SEBASTIAN DETERDING: I said
one of the things in terms
of distinctions, you
typically-- and I apologize
for my terrible handwriting.
This isn't working [INAUDIBLE]
involving AIDS for me.
It is between descriptive
and normative.
Are you using these
terms of indescriptive
or a normative way?
I've seen a lot of
people using gamification
in a normative way. [INAUDIBLE]
communication, evaluating that.
Another one is if you
do a descriptive way,
how do you operationalize
that definition if you say,
it is gamification if
it has certain features,
like an achievement system.
Or is it gamification if
it describes the outcome
of a certain design process?
Designers about to make
something more [INAUDIBLE]
about thinking about [INAUDIBLE]
games to make this more fun.
Then the out come of that,
by definition of unification.
Or not even by the design
process, just by the intention.
Does the user see
this as something
that is gamified or not?
Or did the designer, in doing
this, think about this as now
I'm doing gamification
or not, which
answers the question that some
people here ask saying well,
how come this [INAUDIBLE] of
ordinance called gamification,
whereas we have the
same kind of incentive
schemes in the big corporations
for decades before that?
And key performance indicators,
this intelligence dashboard.
Nobody called it
gamification, even though it
was the exact same thing.
It comes down to how do you
operationalize and formalize
that [INAUDIBLE]?
If you say it's dependent
on tension and you say well,
that wasn't the attention.
This wasn't intended to be
[INAUDIBLE], no matter what
it was [INAUDIBLE].
If I define gamification
by a certain feature list.
So as long as it fits
the feature list.
Yes?
So again, how do
you define the term?
And there, it follows
the [INAUDIBLE].
GABRIELLE
TREPANIER-JOBIN: Maybe you
can talk to kids about the
debates around gamification,
ideologies,
governance, surveyance.
Maybe it's not like you're an
expertise, or I don't know.
SEBASTIAN DETERDING: If I
talk about reproduction,
like gamification of
reproduction, that to me
is an immediate outflow of
[INAUDIBLE] gamification
as government [INAUDIBLE].
GABRIELLE TREPANIER-JOBIN: Mhm.
SEBASTIAN DETERDING: Definitely.
So I'm happy to talk about
governmentality and ideology.
That's a good question.
Other questions in
the room right now?
We also have two more
questions on the board.
Sorry.
AUDIENCE: I was
going back to what
you talked about earlier
on the note of autonomy
being the marker for whether
something feels like a game
or feels like gamification.
I feel like autonomy is almost
a loaded term, in this sense
and that yes, you
could have autonomy,
and that when someone
gives you a test,
you can decide how to do it.
And as long as you return
the test in a finished state,
then you're fine or whatever.
But there's also
not the autonomy
where you can go against the
logic of the system, which
in this case, would be
the logic of the business.
So I feel like in
this example, it
felt more like gamification
or a bad attempt
at gamification to these
people, because the logic was
pretty one directional.
It was only ever increasing the
end product for the business,
not letting OK.
If I want to, I can have
agency against the business.
And that might have
certain consequences,
but it would still
be like I already
know the consequences
beforehand as part
of having some sort of agency.
SEBASTIAN DETERDING: This
leads to an age old question
in humanism.
It goes back to Kant
and the Enlightenment.
It goes back to Aristotle.
That is the question, how do
you not instrumentalize people?
If you take the idea that people
are self-determined actors,
or that they can become--
we can help people race
towards being
self-driven actors.
How can we not make them
other determined actors
in [INAUDIBLE]?
And that's actually an
interesting question for me,
because I started out
working in civic education.
And civic education very much,
at least in Germany thanks
to the Second World War, and
then thanks to the Allied
Forces occupying
Germany and saying,
we should learn a thing
or two about democracy.
So civic education in
Germany, which originally
was a democracy age that happens
very interesting [INAUDIBLE].
How can we create
a democratic state?
Or can we educate
people about democracy
being a good thing
without ourselves
becoming a totalitarian rule?
Without this itself
becoming again, [INAUDIBLE]?
And the argument, or the
point that civic education
in Germany camp as the
moral stem point which
reflects the point that
Aristotle had for education,
in general-- how did we
get to educate people
to become really
selfish [INAUDIBLE]
is to say as long as for
all intensive purposes,
according to your own best
knowledge and intentions
you try to set up this
system of education such
that you enable the person
going through that education
at the end of it to make
the independent judgment
whether that education
is actually the best
possible thing happening to me,
so retrospectively embracing
what was done to [INAUDIBLE]
saying afterwards,
without you training
me some discipline,
I would have never
developed the faculties
in order to be able to be
an independent flourishing
[INAUDIBLE].
So thanks for that.
That was actually
good afterwards, even
though during the process,
I felt other [INAUDIBLE],
and I hated it.
But as long as you're doing
it in my best interest,
to bring me to the situation
where you can reflexively
look at what you did to me
and then say, that was wrong.
Let's change this.
So as long as everybody
going through the system
is the critical
corrector that comes out
to look afterwards at the system
that says this was actually
good, or this was
actually [INAUDIBLE]
way to change the system.
Then things [INAUDIBLE].
So that's the procedural order.
The system is built
with the intention
of making people critical--
changes of the system they
themselves run through,
then it's fine.
Then it supports
their independence
and their autonomy [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: I see.
SEBASTIAN DETERDING: There
are very few businesses
that do that that I'm aware of.
That's in civic education.
Oh there it is.
That's the answer to it.
We'll get to govermentality,
and we'll get to the two others
on the board.
Any other thing that you
would like to be addressed?
[INAUDIBLE] to worry about.
Sweet.
Then let's talk about
governmentality very quick,
and then about what is learning
from games or gamification?
So can we do this
interestingly or responsibly,
and can I have some of it?
So governmentality--
just a show of hands.
Who knows the term
governmentality?
Yeah.
It's this ugly
[INAUDIBLE] created
by Michel Foucault, which
was the bald, gay Frenchman.
It was correct, right?
Anything incorrect here--
GABRIELLE TREPANIER-JOBIN:
It's correct.
SEBASTIAN DETERDING:
I can only say that,
because I wrote
my master's thesis
chugging through old
books of Foucault,
so I feel I've
earned saying that.
Governmentality is
basically-- there
are lots of dimensions of how
it's basically been played.
But one part of that is to
say modern liberal nation
states, in specific, do
not rule by punishment.
They do not rule by if you do x
wrong, I'm going to whack you.
Or if you do x well, I'm
going to give you something.
They rule by putting
people into the mindset
that they individually
regulate themselves
and that they believe.
It's in their own best interest
to regulate their own behavior
that they internalize it.
It's a Freudian argument.
It's not my parents
telling me stuff to do.
I have my inner parents
telling me that I'm horrible.
So in the same way,
the state operates
by getting you to
internalize regulations
so that the state doesn't have
to inefficiently whack you
the whole time.
How does governmentality
connect to games?
Well, you can make the argument
gamification is specific.
Well, we can make the argument,
or I would make the argument
that a big part of how current
Western nation states manage
to keep this governmentality
is to tell us
in order to realize ourselves.
In order to be our best selves,
in order to be all we can be,
we have to self-manage.
We have to self-optimize.
We have to be productive,
productive productive,
and manage ourselves, and
become ever more productive
throughout.
And then gamification
will quantify itself.
All of these are basically
tools society then
gives us or people
give us to say,
these are ways in which you
can manage yourself better,
and these are ways
in which you can
monitor yourself better to make
yourself evermore productive.
And that was supporting
and reinforcing
the very societal system
at which we're all
kept to be as productive as
we can be-- that way, actually
regulating ourselves, instead
of having other people have
to regulate some of that form.
And then you can ask yourself,
is that actually a society
in which I want to live in?
Do I subscribe to that?
So that's my one minute
stick on governmentality.
What is good
learning from games,
or what is good gamification?
I tried in the
Eudaimonic design article
to tease that outwards,
[INAUDIBLE] on how to do this
well would look like, and
there's another article
out the lens of intrinsic skill
[INAUDIBLE] right now on SSRM,
and the proofs
should fly around.
Somewhere we've reached
the [INAUDIBLE] journal.
But there's another
article you could
find online, the lens
of intrinsic skill
[INAUDIBLE] where I describe
an actual design method.
The basic things, I
would say, is do not
put the cart before the voice.
That is if you're
a good designer
you do not say, this is a
solution space, gamification.
Now, where can I use it, but
work the other way around.
Look at the problem
and say, what problem
do I try to solve
in the context?
So good, very practical example.
A friend of mine
uses for Fitbit,
came in Rochester,
Upstate New York.
She walked about
3,000 steps a day.
She's now on a Fulbright
in Croatia in Dubrovnik,
and [INAUDIBLE].
Is that a sudden
boost of motivation?
boost of willpower?
Is that because the Fitbit
has a new feature or some new
achievements to unlock?
It's because if you try to get
around in Dubrovnik with a car,
it's the most complicated
and inefficient way
of getting around.
And the city is basically just
one huge flight of stairs.
So there is no way
for you to do anything
but walk through your whole day.
So if I look, Step
Trackers has this solution
to people's lacking mobility.
I say well, it's not as
if Americans are slackers
and Europeans are
monsters of willpower.
It's just when I was back
in Hamburg, getting around
in [INAUDIBLE] was the easiest,
cheapest, most efficient
way to get form A to B, so
I was biking all the time.
And it was completely
self-sufficient,
because whenever I couldn't
reach something with a bike,
I could reach it with a well
built out public transportation
system.
And drivers, therefore, were
expecting that there were bikes
all the time.
Here, especially in Rochester,
which is a car city-- other way
around.
I couldn't bike,
even if I wanted to.
The city architecture
works against me.
Drivers not being used
to that works against me.
Wrong roads works against me.
So suddenly, I
need all willpower
to put myself against the
friction of the environment
to bike against all odds.
So don't put the cart
before the horse.
Look at the problem
and say oh, we actually
have to change the zoning.
If we introduce
mixed zoning, people
will walk, because there's an
easier way between supermarket
and home, and you will just
walk the small ways [INAUDIBLE].
So that's the first part.
And then the second part
is part of your analysis.
So say to yourself, is
motivation the issue?
What games do well is indeed,
motivate in certain ways.
That are things that are fun
and enjoyable to a lot of kids.
And look at the issue and
say, is motivation really
what is lacking here, motivation
due to a lack of structure,
due to a lack of
frequent feedback,
due to a lack of clearly
explicated goals,
due to a lack of interestingly
varied challenge?
And again, all of these
are the components
by which games
actually create fun,
engaging experience
of competence
being absorbed in the activity.
If that's the case, great.
Take structures from games.
Take those structures.
Have better articulated goals.
Have more frequent feedback.
Vary the challenge
in interesting ways
so I don't do the same old thing
over, and over, and over again.
If that's not the issue, why
should you even try games?
Again, using the wrong tool.
Like 80% of problems
where I get flown in,
I look at whatever software
thinking they built and say,
you have a usability issue.
You don't have an
engagement issue.
First people have to figure out
where even to click before you
have to motivate them
to click, and that's
hard, and [INAUDIBLE] interface.
Let's fix that first.
So that's the short answer.
And the long answer then,
look into that article,
and I go into great lengths
to [INAUDIBLE] one, what is it
we can assure in games?
Any final questions?
GABRIELLE TREPANIER-JOBIN:
Thank you so much.
SEBASTIAN DETERDING: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]